what is going on there so what is going on there
what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here today so with comic-con 2022
taking place and a lot of people have been doing
these marvel announcement videos what to expect
i see it all over social media i put out a post
on our community page and my personal twitter at
the gregg goblet you can follow me asking people
what they are hoping for gets announced
now honestly i'm tampering my expectations
simply because with it being marvel knowing d23
is coming up in like a month and a half they're
probably gonna want to reserve their biggest
mic drop announcements in-house with the mouse
house you know and i know we as fans can be in
dubiously anticipatory of what's to be revealed
and sometimes our own personal desires leave
us disappointed although i am always okay with
being proven wrong i'm engaged trust me i get
it so what i wanted to do today was go through
the responses you loyal citizens put down ever
since i discovered that word citizens i've been
abusing it and i'll give my two cents per mention
to let you know whether i think that's actually
going to happen or whether i don't believe that's
going to happen so let's see what i get right or
what i get wrong come this saturday before we
do that leave a like or a dislike if you already
assumed the whole context of the video based off
the title and secondly really quick in case you
missed our major announcement we partnered up
with heavy spoilers and screen crush to bring
you a one-stop nerd shop called zero edition
where we got some extremely high quality merch
it's a great way to support the channel and show
your love of being a citizen of the reject nation
got some stranger things inspired shirts as well
we got more shorts more variety in development
as we were working with our artists and right now
we got a limited run one meets one to become one
shirt or as pink be three two three eight
zero said on my instagram stranger game squid
things thank you for that it's better than
squitter games all right guys let's get into it
okay so the top comment here says f4 cast that's
fantastic four for sure by the way i think it'd
be a great idea for you three to do like a
prediction video maybe you could even make
a small competition between you i'm just gonna
stop you right here look well first things first
koi is actually a comic con doing several
panels one isn't hall h for keanu reeves
and john brought the vid diesel into my home and i
tested positive for the diesel still got it right
now hoping we're all clear by the time saturday
rolls around to cover all the comic-con goodies
but i'm gonna get this out of the way in terms
of fantastic four i wouldn't get my hopes up
about it i know that's upsetting to some people
for me to say that and don't get me wrong i love
to be wrong in instances like this i just feel
like they're probably going to keep stuff more
focused on stuff they've already announced back
with some smaller announcements maybe a little
bit of exclusive footage and a trailer or two
but i really do believe the f4 cast will be
reserved for d23 and honestly i actually think it
might be cool if they wait for d23 because that's
when they first announced the director who's no
longer the director but that's when they revealed
the logo this seems like it'd be more fitting
kind of like a full circle thing next up mcgoof
i know i nailed that don't correct me because
it's correct i'm hoping to see a black panther
2 teaser trailer deadpool 3 update and fantastic
forecast i don't mind if i don't get anything
else but i want these three without fail i
full-heartedly am expecting a black panther
2 trailer i'd be shocked if we don't get it it's
the next movie set to come out i know they're
doing like a little bit of reshoots right now
it's been like a forever shoot but they got to
have something ready now right they gotta have
something i imagine like this is their event
trailer though and a deadpool 3
update ooh oh that's a good one hmm
i think yeah yeah they've already talked
quite a bit about this movie enough gets
reported on in the trades like he confirmed
to be rated r they got writers director
not confirmed sort of confirmed sean levy so while
i do really believe they're going to preserve
their biggest stuff for d23 they got to have
something really special though to really hype
us up to make their return to comic-con worthwhile
more than just like black panther 2. so yeah i'm
saying yes to deadpool 3. i think there's going
gonna be some deadpool 3 stuff i comic-con next
up is roger i heard the mutants x-men film will be
announced too so definitely this isn't fantastic
for a lot of fantastic four okay with mutants i'm
a little back and forth i think they'll touch on
it i think they're going to touch on the fact
that there are mutants here now because of that
miss marvel ending reveal and you know speaking
of full circle with d23 the first time feige
mentioned we didn't even talk about mutants was
at the last time they were at comic-con so i do
think they'll speak on it where i where i don't
think that what they're gonna do is give an x-men
movie announcement they might give like a mutant
character announcement or maybe that rumored
mutants movie but i don't think we're gonna get an
x-men announcement that's just what my instincts
are telling me but man i would love to be wrong
on that i need a new name i know said dr doom
announcement yeah that's not happening no way no
way in fact i'm hoping they can keep doctor doom
to such secrecy manage to somehow never get that
leaked and that we never find out until we see
him in a post-credits scene but no there's there's
no i see a chief of comments right here actually
that are saying doctor no it's not happening
doctor dude's not gonna get announced ryun
sake again nailed it absolutely nailed it deadpool
three fantastic four another one x-men reboot of
course blade finally a release date of course
i expect captain america for i feel like people
are sleeping on captain america four yeah i think
they'll definitely bring captain america four up
it's kind of lacking in hype and they need to
hype that up but blade yes i'm gonna say yes
because that was one of their major reveals from
the last time they were at comic con and and i
think they would want to follow up on that i think
they are in pre-production right now that would
make sense like just gearing up ready to shoot so
i do think they'll bring something regarding blade
i did hear the rumor about anthony star homelander
possibly playing the character dracula as the
villain i don't believe that although that would
be cool but maybe meet the cast at comic con you
know scrolling through this i i just see a lot
about fantastic four it's making me want to take
backstage but instead it's staying in the vid
prove me wrong comic con powerful cat 72 gaming
says avengers 5 or some kind of movie that ties
together characters from the disney plush shows
if they do announce another avengers movie or
something that ties together the characters like
young avengers or hell even thunderbolts or an
avengers 5 i really think they're going to reserve
that for d23 thunderbolts maybe at comic-con maybe
thunderbolts but in terms of you know the hero
avengers young avengers or avengers 5 highly doubt
that's going to be mentioned here at comic-con
it's got to be reserved for d23 if they're
going to announce it next up is kalis riza la ha
again nailed it knocked it out of the park don't
correct me what i want to see seriously is updates
to quantum mania guardians of the galaxy three
and possibly the fantastic forecast my god i
i i feel like i'm gonna really bite some dust here
you guys are making me doubt myself but i just i
just don't believe it's gonna be announced i'd
love for you to be honest don't play fantastic
what's gonna get it i'm willing to eat my shoes
now this i honestly think we'll see more details
ant-man quantum mania i believe they're
in post-production right now possibly on
reshoots most likely but i i do doubt we'll
get footage although you know a lot of times
it's just about bringing the cast out and you
know the director introducing them so be cool
to meet the new cassie lang they won't explain
what happened to the other actress but it would
be great to bring out jonathan majors to talk a
little bit more about king maybe some like you
know footage reveals a little bit or or like some
photo reveals but you know marvel they're they're
backed up in the vfx department right now i don't
know if you've ever heard anything about this but
apparently it's kind of a [__] show hence why i
doubt they'd show us anything from the film they
tend to reserve their trailers or footage like
two or three months before the movie comes out
now in terms of guardians 3 they just rap filming
they probably need to do some additional reshoots
although this can be a cool opportunity to bring
will poulter out on stage it was revealed that
he's playing adam warlock not at some grand
events it would be cool to bring him out there
james gunn can vehemently defend chris brett the
way he does i like chris brett maybe they'll tell
us who chukwudi uh uh ujji i think how you say
saying the guy from peacemaker that hasn't been
confirmed who is playing yet i highly doubt that
if high evolutionary is in this movie that they're
going to be like we got the high evolutionary
although that would be a banger but so i do
expect some guardians 3 stuff but what i'm really
expecting is a trailer for i am groot because
that show comes out in just a few weeks and
maybe some footage or a teaser trailer for
the guardian's holiday special and just while
i'm on the subject she-hulk trailer i expect a
she-hulk trailer as well really placing my bets on
the ones that everyone's really wanting yup yeah
the vibe i'm getting is a fantastic four is not
announced there'll be some people feeling let down
that's the main demand it's the main demand it's
making me doubt but i'm gonna stay strong swayam
daredevil continuation not a reboot well it's
already been reported on so i i think the reboot
though is actually still a continuation of sorts i
imagine it's gonna be more like a soft reboot what
would be great is if they do bring the daredevil
show to comic-con that they bring the whole
cast out but i feel like they're probably gonna
make mention of devil what i imagine they'll do
is redirect focus back on to ekko will we get an
echo trailer i doubt it but they'll probably talk
about it dion says i'm either hoping for a scarlet
witch movie announcement or a new superman movie
with henry cavill announcement did a video about
that yesterday starting to have my doubts though
because i hear he's filming witcher 3 in london
right now so maybe he doesn't have time but in
terms of solo scarlet witch uh very very unlikely
just a few months ago they tried tricking us into
thinking that she's dead she's not she's not
dead i don't have confirmed sources here but
come on she's not dead but same thing with like
how daredevil was brought up i think instead of
scarlet witch they're gonna be probably talking
about house of harkness and give us details on
that next up walter lopez i like this one i can't
wait to hear the words morbius the more fun stuff
version i would love that yeah come on sony marvel
make it happen don't be cowards let's see let's
get one more in here and one more um cinema tv
i'm run burgundy deadpool 3 rogue hero thor rise
of valhalla x-men minnesota g2 captain america
serpent society good titles but yeah definitely
no thor 5 news nope not gonna happen and i don't
think we're going to hear anything about shanghai
too at comic-con maybe d23 for shanghai too
but thor 5 we went here for a while they'll
be announced with the new director they can reign
in take some up and coming indie director off the
street and being like you listen unless you tone
down that goddamn comedy so yeah as i'm scrolling
through this the main ones i keep seeing are
fantastic four easily the most predominant one
uh something with mutants x-men i actually feel
like something like that is a little more likely
than fantastic four simply due to the ending of
miss marvel blade is the thing a lot of people
want um details on you know it's kind of a
toss up here i just think don't expect too
much but expect the big one to really be d23
and whatever we get just learn to appreciate
it but yeah guys this was fun i appreciate you
guys being here and uh couldn't contribute into
the narrative of the video uh so subscribe click
that bell leave a like and hey you know what we do
brandon benzie thank you for becoming a sexy
reject you get a traditional first shout out
b stands for bitchin r stands for rad sandwich
a stands for awesome tacular buy it on blu-ray
d stands for drunkalicious cause yamil woozy
oh stands for auto octavius because you're a
genius and n stands for you cannot say that
word you you are not allowed to say that word
let me look at your profile pic i can confirm
you're not allowed to say that word stop it
you know what word appreciate you
being here buddy hope you enjoyed
your first shout out and i was quick on
that one and we will talk to you guys soon